made a small parkour course with the new
honey mechanics what what you can run on
walls in Minecraft what
that's so epic welcome everyone my name
is Pete
I lost my minecraft save file okay first
of all I'm sorry I have a backup on
another computer I just don't have
access to that computer so instead of
playing Minecraft we can watch other
people play minecraft minecraft
subreddit also got a new microphone so
now no one can make fun of me for
putting a microphone on top of a
microphone hopefully this does not sound
bad I don't know yet this texture pack
was supposed to be a joke should I keep
going yes let's make the kids game look
more like a kids game
no I'm just kidding it actually looks
cool I'm sorry nether update officially
confirmed yeah so what is in the nether
update okay so now pig Ling's won't
attack you while wearing golden armor
cool thanks minecraft god remember when
I used to make fun of Mike looking
forward to new update it's gonna be
awesome cool a little bed design okay
that's really cool actually I like that
can't find designer to credit okay I'll
use that in the future made a resource
pack that connects would like this
thoughts why nice bug I found or does
the bug exactly oh oh wow you can run
with one or even Jesus Christ
oh no oh poor cow are you thinking what
does it work with sheeps hmm council of
beetroot will be pleased
some little structure idea cuz there's
no in-game hints about nether portal
that's really cool that's a great idea
in case of emergency break glass that's
great that's awesome I get it because I
play Minecraft I just wanted to share
this in this subreddit okay
that's a cool shader pack I want it oh
is it the same house in different scale
oh god stop
you should have ended there oh god the
bed is old babe
make it stop Oh God come on Jesus Christ
no it continues oh my god
Jesus what do people do with their spare
time actually I know commands that you
can fill in quite easily certain blocks
nevermind I don't know anything that's
still impressive I'm not gonna lie okay
stop okay that's impressive that's very
very very very impressive it takes long
just to enter it oh my god haha she says
it makes me anxious I don't know why
that's actually really cool you got
clouds inside your house after many
failed attempts I finally got it right
behold my scatter anvil cannon what an
anvil cannon woah that's cool
what do you do with it a candle an
animal cannon is a fun idea maybe I'll
do something then okay that's kind of
cool
using different textures to make it seem
wet Jesus Christ what has happened to me
Mike right that's our cringy well that's
cool they're like using different type
of wood to make the wood look soaked in
water that's so cool Wow well that is
sick I'm an environment designer what
does that mean I just feel bad about how
bad my buildings are now just finish my
survival basement main hall Oh God
whoa I need to get shaders so I can have
water like that that looks so cool when
it's the Nvidia thing coming out what is
that oh it's an elevator to go back up
oh my god I'm impressed brah roller
coaster huh
has nothing on my dolphin roller coaster
whoa whoa still my dolphin roller
coaster is better I'm not gonna sit here
and pretend that I'm amazed by this
unless something very cool happens very
soon this part would go underneath water
for me Oh what oh that's funny
what oh my god that's awesome oh you can
slow down the roller-coaster again what
is wrong with you okay that's pretty
cool what do you guys think dolphin yeah
it's not even a question just a little
boat just a little boat just found a way
to make an instant bridge in Minecraft
what how what is happening what am I
looking at
instant bridge okay all right let's see
it are they all packed in there oh my
god that's so cool instant bridge Wow I
like how he doesn't even walk on the
bridge
don't play with potion kids haha oh my
god what Salieri's after all these years
I finally have the Mauer
them or what oh god this is the thing
that I don't know in Minecraft that's
embarrassing
what is this
I'm so confused oh it's got milk wow I
actually have no idea what I just
witnessed self-controlling AI
pathfinding bond so it's calculating
around but where is it going damn it's
working really well
hello ready that's cool we did it by
popular demand slime box blocks and
honey blocks don't stick together oh
cool
hooray that's cool that they're
listening to fans and and suggestions
that's really awesome this resource pack
has camouflage creeper that blend in
with the biome they spawn in my god
I've seen this thanks Satan I kind of
want to try it just for the mean maybe
I'll try it for one episode my room and
I just lost this survival world we
worked over a year on this is the only
evidence of it ever existing enjoy whoa
oh damn oh you lost everything this is
so sad
F's in the chat flying queen bee using
honey blocks god I'm such a nerd what
happened to me so I drew a desert temple
on my calculator that's really cool made
a birthday cake for my boyfriend
complete with porch oh my god
much my birthday's coming up marzia the
tallest staircase with one block
fifteen blocks the tallest staircase
within one block okay got it
whoa that spawn randomly this circular
ravine my friend found this is minecraft
so cool when you're in your 40s have no
idea how to play Minecraft and are
trapped in a pillager outpost by a
zillion villagers but you have to get
the hell out of here okay
you have no idea I play Minecraft but
you know how to set up slow-motion shots
in the third-person perspective am I
supposed to believe this listen I'm a
true minecraft veteran who doesn't know
how to play minecraft alright don't even
pretend that you don't know how to play
minecraft added pizza-making game what
but why but why that's not pizza that's
fries brah
that's the melon soda they have that in
Japan bro you put fries on your pizza
brah cat I guess so
okay I know this one I know this one
that's a light that's a power source
that's a switch I used to be really good
at I don't know what it's calling
English I designed a simple yet flashing
you five-by-five door with redstone
wow it's that's a really good idea
actually to have the nether world in
different colors
I hope they pick up on small stuff like
this I built a big sandwich in Minecraft
what do you think I think it's awesome
Cod launcher card launcher how did you
make something so brave and
controversial I made a Halloween themed
sign that's cool too every once a week
I'm giving random minecraft tips tips 1
trap a llama in a boat with an attached
chest to serve as extra storage for your
boat bonus it makes your boat a
battleship because of llama spits boner
spits a Minecraft piston made in my year
10 robotics class oh yeah well can you
free creeper with it
I'll waste my time ten years of Robotics
Jesus Christ bruh
even without shaders this game is
absolutely beautiful sometimes just a
piston
oh god no stop thanks I hate it
placing one water source between two
layers of magma blocks causes it to
multiply infinitely an other pointless
trivia to know you can put a bed inside
a bed for a better bedroom why that is
pretty cool actually this is a bunch of
Betty White
[Music]
Fox in the caldron Fox in caldron a tiny
end island or is it what this custom
mushroom biome looks perfect okay that's
a little black sheep you asking me I
made a simple and quick honey block
elevator what how does that work how
does that work I want to make that
that's so cool
14-3 that's pretty cool actually tea
posing Steve what the hell giant
prehistoric creeper I like that too man
people are so created a better looking
way to make honey wall runs I'm not sure
what you're talking about
oh that's cool
people are so creative I'm not even
pretending to not be a dweeb anymore I
don't even care okay that's awesome
oh god that makes me think of our old
resident is room I made Mario Kart Wii
Nintendo 64 Bowser's Castle what that's
awesome
I should call the concept survival
creation that's so dumb
I didn't think I would have been able to
pull this off for what is he doing
whoa get the water get the water oh well
done the panic of getting the water
midair that's a pro-gamer move right
there the reaction time I can't believe
it that's awesome
ah fun tip you can put a block in an
item frame with a sign that is a fun tip
and I will take chicken neat little
Kitchener sign that's so cute I want to
build all this this is great inspiration
powered rails are a thing of the past
are you what stop you can put boats in
Minecraft the most intense moment I've
ever had
cheese sighs oh god he's gonna make it
Oh God brah well plane EEP
that was awesome 8x8 sand door
okay that's dope impress it how does he
work it takes some time though whoa whoa
what how does it know when to change
layer brah that's really impressive
Oh sneak peek at Mount ravine itself god
I just feel bad about how bad I am at
Minecraft now stop everyone's building
all these epic things meanwhile I just
built a meatball and that was I was
mildly caught off guard and didn't know
how to react so I just stopped okay
okay so there is working conveyor belt
using honey blocks man I can't wait to
use honey blogs also items stick - honey
blocks I didn't know that not sure what
you would use it for but I guess you can
transport items the highest one block
staircase 40 blocks tall okay I guess
they beat their record what I built a
guillotine
oh my god no how does that work
it dropped an anvil that's hilarious
hidden port ideas for my base epic never
spawn a wither under your babes oh god
it escaped Oh God whoa how do people do
this liked bra that's incredible
oh my god yes they're making frogs in
Minecraft I can't wait to get one name
it slippy man I'm so excited to playing
Minecraft now yeah I saw those randomly
on Twitter this guy made food place
phase in Minecraft
[Music]
whoa run there it is
that's sick bruh bruh bruh thank you man
I can't wait to build a guillotine in
Minecraft there it is again
protip add spruce planks alongside oak
planks to make them look wet wow that's
so awesome
lightning Trident level hundred oh god I
can't wait to see this no not the check
edge whoa how do you do that oh it's a
command block can you use command blocks
in survival is that legal is that
illegal will I go to Minecraft jail try
to make a portal creation animation
another command block oh okay
that's cool
yeah that's dub a closet design it's not
bad
be careful when using boats in the
nether make sure you test your eyes
roads or else this could happen what
what does a buttons do does that make it
faster whoa Wow things like this I made
it so insane that I made it for five
years in hardcore like there's so many
random ways you could just go yes
with noteblocks amping hmm yeah yeah all
right gamers hope you guys enjoy this
episode I had fun as always I actually
have a song of my own coming out
hopefully this week it's a minecraft
song I'm really excited for it
smash like if you want to see it and I
see you gamers next time bye bye
well you haven't tried to Bruce emulator
since me
after 50 million out troops by etch I am
down just down it's still relevant just
down a bit